we got some new merch made but it's only
exclusive for our petrie honors
so if you go on our patreon we got some
new tiers we got the coffee mug tear
and the hoodie tier and if you're
defibrillator you get
both so make sure you go to patreon
check that out and thank you guys so
much for supporting and enjoy the video
[Music]
have you guys heard of who bill bill
gross is
yeah bill brooke oh gross
that sounds very familiar it sounds very
it's just a very plain name i think
really
the girl's the science guy bill gates
the science guy
oh my god that face literally he looks
pretty gross
let's talk about scary movies it looks
like he put
like a freaking hannibal after his skin
yeah i hope he's not doing some [ __ ]
philanthropic [ __ ] and we're all talking
[ __ ] about him like he just rescued
70 children he looks like um smeagol and
the dad from
third rock from the sun he looks like
the animaniacs version of beethoven
is he with the horn or like edgar allen
code
yeah it looks like he has a dangly
earring ah
he's got gauges all right so bill gross
he is i hope he's a bad guy he is gonna
explode in like five seconds please be a
bad guy we talk so much [ __ ]
okay he'll be dead by the time this
comes out don't worry
so he's known as the bond king
he's made he's a billionaire and he has
made his money
uh through running an investment
management company thingy he's
whatever right so he's in the news right
now because
he's in a legal battle with his neighbor
because of his elaborate lawn
sculpture like it's a dick lawn
sculpture
i knew it on his laguna beach mansion
property i love the gonna be it's so
nice
it's nice have you driven through it
yeah it's [ __ ] i like the show
why you're so young i'm really i think i
love that show
so crazy i had to find it on youtube do
you guys know that
there used to be tv there was this thing
called television
oh yeah so this is a sculpture that
they're going into battle over
so hold on there's no dicks what's wrong
with that you brought that up
no no i know i'm talking to myself oh
what's wrong with it is it mermaid tails
what is that
this one is it's like a glass blown
sculpture apparently it was very very
very expensive and
bill gross bought it for his girlfriend
gross
for her 18th birthday she is
significantly younger her name is amy
schwartz and she's a
ex-pro tennis or something oh okay you
gotta love when the
when your young bride is she looks like
she stole that trophy i know it's
mine she looks like she's forcing a
[ __ ] smile like nobody else yeah you
can't have it
[Laughter]
so they're in a legal battle with their
neighbors and
the neighbor his name is mark tofic and
he's a
tech entrepreneur along with his wife
what are these last
names right next to them this is some
like billionaire battle [ __ ]
that's like we i don't get it i like how
they look better though they're jeans
they're down to earth they're cute
they're
age-appropriate for each other [ __ ] i
mean we know the richest
people are [ __ ] petty as [ __ ] i love
you wait till we get to the petty part
so let me show you some more photos okay
so this is paper battles
so this is bill gross's statue right or
sculpture he got it for amy five out of
ten frankly so
for amy she was saying that like uh
because
it somehow has a tie-in with her mom who
she loves very much and so
because amy doesn't have children of her
own these sculptures are like her babies
and so [ __ ] off aboard a board
and so apparently there was this one
time where they noticed some significant
damage to the sculpture so they decided
to put up this netting which this is a
photo from the neighbor's property oh
you can't do that yeah it's from the
neighbor's property
ugly this is what it looks like at night
it looks pretty good at night actually i
do like the night yeah that's really
pretty
yeah it reflects the light yeah look at
that it's like reflecting
it looks cheap cheap ass taste that's
like
it's like vegas during the day frankly
because the night looks so sick and then
during the day you're like oh
they put this netting because they're
saying that because of they thought that
there was like some rocks that were
being thrown who's throwing these
[ __ ] rocks kind of accusing
this neighbor oh of doing that
they're not rich enough psychic are we
like best friends oh my god
they actually do have cameras and they
and so mark rose was saying that
uh wait bill gross was saying that mark
his neighbor is like some
creepy ass neighbor because they have
cameras pointed towards their property
and they
they can see whenever bill and amy go
into the pool
and that they have like very little or
if any clothing on and that is just very
invasive
and and then so they're pretty much kind
of insinuating that
you've seen you nobody wants to see you
naked yes and plus bill gross can block
the camera with his head
and by the way the cameras can angle
cannot catch how
low those balls are hanging well mainly
it's with amy because she's the younger
hotter one she's like i'm in my early
70s i'm very young i'm a spring chicken
she's 51. do they have like 7 71's
oh my god i am really having some mental
prowess
mental paralysis paralysis proud prowess
but like like [ __ ] birds will get
like uh
seeds and like nuts and stuff and they
fly with it and that [ __ ] could be
breaking it
why they got it true so then that's why
they put the net and also
that was [ __ ] by the way in your life
when your parents were like these are
just seeds that was them just
[ __ ] oh taking a [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
it's all white i know also it's like it
seems i don't know
yes it did it's tacky bro oh that
initial damage that i mentioned earlier
it was
apparently worth more than 50 000 worth
of damage
which is nothing to a billionaire why
don't these idiots just [ __ ] put a
net or something literally
on top of like why does it have to be so
how about glass blow a [ __ ] enclosure
exactly and add to the sculpture
that's true just break the first layer
of glass okay so then
gross found out that mark wanted to
uh complain well first of all mark had
approached them apparently very politely
and saying like hey
can you do something about that netting
like it's literally blocking the view of
our home it's [ __ ] up it's against the
city code or whatever
and nothing ever happened so then
eventually
that's when bill gross found out that
mark the neighbor was gonna go to the
city to complain so then that's when
bill comes in
preemptively and throws him a lawsuit
whoa
he's like oh you want a [ __ ] i
thought you guys thought he broke up
with things and came in to stab him to
death with it
no he he sued him his billionaire
it looks like um oh we're not connected
anymore i'm not getting anything
game of thrones what do they call it
dragon glass dragon claws yeah it looks
like dragon
glass it's just obsidian yeah yeah me
and your husband are super connected
it's okay it happens a lot but you
should check his phone gotta keep
calling back all the other nobody knows
what you're talking about
fallbacks all day i can't help but okay
it's okay but the reason why
this is making headlines though is for
the pettiest part of this entire story
which is that bill gross
now is he's blasting loud ass
music oh [ __ ] off bizarre audio
recordings
at excessive levels including like
dolphin mating calls no including
gilligan's island
theme song that's nice i would love that
i would have been outside dancing like
yeah and then he's sitting in there with
with soundproof headphones and he's
smiling
with his bows on
when yeah ruin their own lives to ruin
someone else's life
like the left of the whole thing they're
just like laughing like
well the thing is too that uh so gross
was saying that
they are the best neighbors because
they're only at their home for five days
out of a month
five months out of the year oh damn and
so
the neighbor mark is like yeah we
[ __ ] know that they're remotely
setting off these audio recordings
because they're not even at home
so both of them don't even live there
and they're just [ __ ] bad mark lives
there
oh my god live there look bill gross
like here's a
what about all the other neighbors i
know right [ __ ] the properties
where is this okay so this is one
property this is bill gross's property
and this is mark's property and it's
straight up on the beach though that's
gonna be that's where the wow is
so right here here's the sculpture
because i'm looking at the picture and i
see his [ __ ] cane too it's just
rubber
so this is this is so blend i don't even
know what he's pointing at
this is martial yeah he's like take a
look at this thing
that's his property it does suck that
like
just put the sculpture like over there
there just obviously did it to troll
them they are being dead
also mark was saying how those are her
children that is the most pathetic
yeah mark get friends [ __ ] how's your
eggs [ __ ] you could be having them now
you're only 51 you're a spring chicken
but yeah mark was saying that bill gross
is clearly just the [ __ ]
billionaire brat but he's just so used
to getting his way and that's why he's
being such a
petty ass [ __ ] about all this by
blasting the music
[ __ ] preemptively preemptively suing
them
and so now the mark is like countersuing
and all this [ __ ] it's just
a lot of petty buildings i want to see
who wins why can't they just buy the
house next to them
and then just leave that house empty and
then they don't have to deal with each
other
who buys the other house whichever one
they're billionaires
yeah they're both [ __ ] buy the house
on the other side and play music
you know what it is rich people can't
they can't believe when their money
can't control everything
they cannot believe it well dude i'd be
the i'm honestly on mark's side because
he's been there since 2009 and gross
just came in
2018. i'm on his side too it's like why
are you making it all gross and that's
the statues are your kit just move the
stat be cool dude just
it doesn't put your kids inside your
house next to your bed right yeah you're
letting your kids at least
you're leaving them there five months
out of the year you're leaving your kids
outside
mm-hmm that's pretty weird too is that
bad i don't know i don't have kids
it's okay sometimes they're dirty that's
where they pee right
but yeah so it's just petty ass [ __ ]
but the thing that everyone's running
with is the fact that he's blasting
gilligan
gilligan's island i love that song the
skipper too
yeah take the money for a week
i say take their money for one whole
week and then they'll come back and be
like oh so
sorry man they'll hug each other they'll
cry both of them yeah both of them
yeah if you freeze their assets for one
week isn't it funny that like no matter
how much money you make it just doesn't
change
people like you still fight with your
neighbor you still have petty ass drama
none of this [ __ ] changes it's just
scaled way up yeah and now their battles
are just
costing
is this what they did his face lift with
they like they chopped his face up with
that
it's a surgical instrument you know what
it reminds me of that um
throwaway paper cup with the [ __ ]
yeah the dixie
it does the bottom part like it's become
i mean like people
wear it as t-shirts and [ __ ] now oh like
the pattern yeah
look at this face though that's scary
he's like he's gonna hunt wait so they
call him the bond guy because
he's like three hour tour he sells bonds
like jail bonds and [ __ ] like that
and what they wrote in the article is
that he made his like stocks and bonds
yeah
oh investments damn dude that's crazy
i wonder if he's into stocks in bondage
uh i hope
not gross no is this does she look like
she's in it
yes she's like i love being tied up
you can't have my stuff tie me up i feel
like it's the opposite
she's the dom or she's like the uh
master
and then he likes to be in an assless
chap oh god
dude she does she does love inanimate
objects you said acids
chaps and it's making me think that it's
only one butt cheek exposed
an assless chap just on one side yeah
i love that yep
[Music]
you